hey this is Steve on Trobe with Collider
and I am here in the collider studio at
the Kia Telluride supper suite with
everyone behind down hill here at the
Sundance Film Festival I want to start
by saying congrats on the movie
sincerely I have many things I want to
talk about with this thing but most
people have not like seen footage or are
that familiar with the film so do you
guys want to sort of do the generic
thing and sort of say what it's about
yes for me I wanted to
no one cares for this bit okay it's a
film about a family on a ski vacation
and they are they are having a good time
and everything's going very well and
they're in Austria I should say and it's
an American family and they're sitting
outside a restaurant and all of a sudden
there's a loud boom and there's an
avalanche very far off in the distance
and it looks cool and everybody stands
up to take pictures and then the
avalanche starts coming closer and
people are sort of wandering wandering
and then the Avalanche it seems his upon
them and the mother played by myself
with her to grab her two children and
her husband played by mr. Will Ferrel
behind me yes grabs his cellphone and
runs away
and that is the beginning of the picture
and the rest the picture is the
unraveling of that particular sweater
for the rest of the film and how this
couple and this family reconciled that
moment and they drive a Kia which
ironically keeps breaking down
one of the things that I thought was
great about this is that it is not
Hollywood eyes this is a realistic
depiction of a family and what would
happen but but being serious like it's
it's characters that I think fans of
yours might not be used to you know like
it this isn't being played for Laughs
this is not you know this is a serious
relationship can you sort of talk about
if that what if that's what drew you to
to the script and if you guys can talk
about the fact that this is being
depicted very realistically who's going
first
well it is what drew us to the script be
quiet please
because I think will and I were both
drawn to the drama of the script and the
the and it's a character driven drama
but it also has aspects of comedy within
it but they're pretty authentic comedic
moments born out of real situations
they're not broad per se but it was a
chance for us to flex a little dramatic
muscle and it's also all of us being
such fans of the original which totally
as jim has so astutely it there's a
cringe factor throughout the movie where
you're once this suppose that Avalanche
happens you're kind of uneasy throughout
the whole film and and to kind of you
know stay on that that tightrope through
a project was something that I think
appealed to us as well and I think that
you know we with the way way back and
now with downhill like we are attracted
to stories about flawed characters and
also the balance between comedy and
drama because obviously we live our days
consistently with laughing and crying
within seconds of each other sometimes
because that's where no I know I let me
just share some pain that I am dealing
with and I know this is a weird time to
do this but Kia's asked me to so but I
think that's that for us is what we love
and the the storytelling of this and was
in force-majeure and in town Hill as
well which is this balance of these
characters who are very real had just
very extreme circumstance and like a
play you're they're both sort of
structure in a play you're watching
these two characters basically their
hearts change will they be together
where they won't be together and so it's
this one incident you sort of watch this
journey that has a ripple effect for
them and that's why we like the balance
of laughing through moments that kind of
make us cringe and feel like this is
really serious
one of the things is that well just for
people that are watching even though
there's a lot of serious moments there's
plenty of levity in the film which
brings me to your character with was
everything that you said one of the
things is there is such I mean we could
as we're watching this you're seeing how
funny everybody is how much is what you
said scripted how much are people adding
to it in the moment because I mean they
theater that I saw it and people were
laughing very very hard at what you were
saying you know the first day that we
had on set that I had on well and we had
this dinner party scene and I have never
had such a hard time keeping a straight
face so I'm usually pretty good at not
going up but these guys were so funny
and they improvised a lot as well as the
script so there was there's a quite a
bit of improvisation in there like
little bits at the end of scenes and
stuff like that but the script was so
great like so well observed my
characters kind of mysterious her name's
Charlotte she is at the hotel when they
turn up and she seems to work at the
hotel but they can never really quite
get a handle on does she work there or
is she just a guest at the hotel and she
kind of insinuates herself in their life
and brings her European values to the
table about about life and
individuality sexuality she's kind of an
in-your-face kind of character that is
very accurate I want to say more but I
want people to enjoy the movie for the
two of you you guys sort of join the
film and I would say well you're
mentioned throughout the entire film but
you can join in like the second act yes
so talk a little bit about who you guys
play and how much fun maybe you had
making the film we play a couple who are
in the sort of early serotonin soaked
phases of love where you don't notice
the cracks in the plaster between the
two of you and so we're sort of a foil a
little bit to these guys who are much
further down the road and we're on a
European we're kind of like exploratory
adventurous trip to Europe together
right and we overlap their trip and then
kind of get dragged into their family
drama and have very different reactions
to the situation yeah
was this one of these shoots that you
guys had a blast on was it did it ever
feel challenging there was will you tell
one of the drivers on the production was
such a nice guy but this is my favorite
thing that happened on on on one of the
drives from the airport said you know
it's so funny because we shot in Austria
he said 80 years ago we were fighting
over pretty much nothing and now look at
us and that was my choice
and that was my ride from the airport
that's not true your character also adds
some levity to downhill can you sort of
mention who you play that's very true
I'm obsessed with the editing process
because that is the final rewrite I'm
curious could you talk a little bit
about how maybe the film was adjusted in
the editing room or was it what you
envisioned going in yeah it was a sort
of long and arduous process because what
was important to us I think was really
finding the right tone for the movie and
we all collectively talked you know
before we started shooting about what we
were hoping to achieve and you know it's
it's a delicate matter because you have
these kind of two incredible actors who
are more you know recognized for comedy
a lot of the time and with our film I
think we wanted to not mislead the
audience into that this was going to be
a big broad comedy because it's really
about real people and real emotional
circumstances right yeah so I don't know
I just lost my breath like I was having
a heart attack in the editing process we
just wanted to make sure that we felt
even all the way through I think and not
push the comedy too hard but also
provide you know moments of levity like
you suggested that that sort of relief
that released the pressure in those sort
of bigger emotional scenes yeah we had I
mean we had scenes came in and out of
certain cuts which was kind of
interesting because you move one piece
and that affects everything as you know
but that really
- to the tone of it all it's like we had
a key scene in the beginning of the
movie that was sort of them arriving it
was funny and but we were thinking does
this mislead you into the wrong movie
cuz soon as that Avalanche hits it sort
of is driven by that Avalanche and by
that I mean it's such a dramatic moment
that all the comedy after that really is
paid off from that drama so we found
ourselves like you know trying pretty
drastic cuts just to say oh my god
that's that's the movie that we're
looking for you know so so it was
definitely a process it eventually came
together - a lot with the our composure
and the vocal berdal man who did all the
composing for the film and I think when
we added music to the film it really
helped even the tone in a way that we
were hoping for because it sort of
provided this kind of nice it just
settled it in a way that that maybe it
hadn't previously I sincerely want to
say thank you so much for coming by the
studio answering our fun questions and
have a fantastic have a fantastic
Sundance thank you so much thank you
very much sorry about that heart attack